Easter eggs are a common occurrence in modern
cinema.
Directors love to include inside jokes and
references to other movies and franchises
in their work, simply for the fun of doing
it.
Some are extremely obvious and in plain sight,
while others are sneakily hidden, and part
of the fun of the viewing experience for audiences
is trying to find them - heck, there's still
a confirmed Easter egg from 2014's Guardians
of the Galaxy that hasn't been found yet!
Damn you James Gunn!
This video will highlight some of the mostly
cunningly hidden Easter eggs that HAVE been
found.
Here are ten cleverly hidden Easter eggs that
are hard to spot.
Deadpool
There were a near-endless number of Easter
eggs in 2016's brilliantly hilarious Deadpool
movie and a couple of them actually referred
to DC superhero Batman - one of which was
very well hidden by the commotion that was
taking place at the time.
When Ryan Reynold's titular character jumps
into an SUV and fights against a group of
bad guys, the radio changes station as he
gets his head slammed against it.
If you listen intently enough, you’ll hear
the iconic transition music from the 1960s
live-action Adam West Batman television show!
Anchorman: The Legend of Ron Burgundy
This particular fun Easter egg in 2004's Anchorman:
The Legend of Ron Burgundy is actually far
from "hidden" - in fact it's clear for all
to see in big writing on a big restaurant
sign - but it's hard to spot because it's
written in Spanish!
It's the name of the restaurant visted by
Veronica Corningstone and her female co-worker.
It's called "Escupimos en su Alimento" which,
to the non-Spanish speaker, seems cultured
enough.
However, in Spanish, what that actually means
is "We spit in your food".
Nice.
Doctor Strange
As with all Marvel Cinematic Universe movies,
2016's Doctor Strange was full of Easter eggs
and references to the extended Marvel universe
- but one very important one seems to have
gone under the radar because it was only briefly
and vaguely mentioned.
Karl Mordo used a staff called the Staff of
the Living Tribunal when he was training Stephen
Strange.
In the comic books, the Living Tribunal is
the second most powerful character in all
of Marvel - second to only the One Above All.
If this staff harnesses his power, it could
literally be more powerful than the Infinity
Gauntlet and could be the key to defeating
Thanos in the MCU's Infinity War.
Raiders of the Lost Ark
There are actually a number of Easter eggs
linking the Indiana Jones franchise to the
Star Wars franchise - and they can be found
in movies in both franchises - but the best
of them arguably appears sneakily hidden in
the first Indiana Jones movie, Raiders of
the Lost Ark.
Harrison Ford's Indie has just lifted the
lid off a sarchophagus and he turns around
to look at a pillar behind him.
On that pillar, amongst the many hieroglypics
carved into it, there are hieroglyphic versions
of Star Wars characters C-3PO and R2-D2.
The Incredible Hulk
This is a very well-hidden Easter egg - not
only because it's hard to spot even when it's
on the screen in front of your, but because
it actually only appears in a deleted scene
that can only be seen on the Blu-ray and DVD
of 2008's The Incredible Hulk.
It's a scene in which Bruce Banner heads to
the Arctic Circle to commit suicide.
If you look very close, you can see Captain
America under the snow and ice, foreshadowing
his resurrection from his frozen grave just
a couple of movies later in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe franchise.
Jurassic World
One of the unsung popular characters from
the original Jurassic Park was Mr. DNA - the
animated DNA strand who appeared in the video
John Hammond showed to park guests about how
the park's scientists had recreated dinosaurs.
The character makes a brief appearance in
the new visitor’s centre in 2015's Jurassic
World, which is an Easter egg in itself, but
there's more: Director Colin Trevorrow actually
did the voice for him.
The original voice actor, Greg Burson, has
sadly passed away, and some effects were applied
to Trevorrow’s voice to hide it and make
it sound like the original.
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice is another
comic book movie with lots of Easter eggs,
but one example in the 2016 movie was particularly
exciting for fans of a certain Batman villain
- and we're not talking about The Joker.
When Batman is looking for a place to fight
Superman, some stone pillars can be seen covered
in graffiti.
Hidden amongst the graffiti is a question
mark - a sure-fire sign that the enigmatic
Riddler (who has, of course, previously been
played by Jim Carrey on the big screen in
Batman Forever) exists in the current DC movie
universe!
Finding Nemo
Disney's movies - and, in particular, their
Pixar movies - are known for including clues
that suggest all of them take place in the
same universe.
2003's Finding Nemo has a prime example of
this hidden in the middle of the credits.
Just as the "Special Thanks" section of the
credits begins to roll, none other than Mike
- the round green monster with a single big
eyeball from 2001's Monsters, Inc. - can be
seen swimming across the scene wearing a mask
and snorkel.
He looks towards the camera and goes on his
merry way.
The Rocky Horror Picture Show
Here we come to the most literal example of
"hidden Easter eggs" in a movie - and it's
rumoured to be the origin of the term as well
- and it comes from the 1975 classic The Rocky
Horror Picture Show.
The movie's cast decided to have an Easter
egg hunt on the set, with a number of eggs
being so well hidden that they weren't found
and removed before filming resumed.
Several made it into the final movie, including
one under Dr. Frank N. Furter’s throne,
one on a lamp in the main hall, and another
near the lab's elevator.
Suicide Squad
2016's Suicide Squad was absolutely teaming
with Easter eggs - most of which were links
to the expanded DC movie universe - but one
well-hidden example refers to the larger themes
of the movie as a whole.
It's the scene when Harley Quinn smashes a
store window to pick out a designer handbag.
The background shows words written in Latin
- and they aren't just random words.
The phrase “si vis pacem para bellum”
- which is repeated over and over - means
“if you want peace, prepare for war.”
That’s Amanda Waller’s belief based on
the fact that a metahuman war is coming that
the world needs to prepare for.
Thanks for watching our video about ten cleverly
hidden Easter eggs that are hard to spot.
Did you enjoy this video?
Which other Easter eggs took a very keen eye
on the part of the viewer to notice?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.